well maybe this is something that might
pique your interest because we talk
about the planet we talked about we
talked about with resource depleting
there seems to be a drive with the
millennial generation and with the
generation Z seems to be driven to the
shared economy we're now doing things
more for the Instagram you can rent a
dress for a day or you can go and have
an experience at like the ice cream
factory or whatever from a stream using
for a day you can rent a car a nice car
for one day and you get the experience
and you take an Instagram photo and
that's it and it's a shared economy in
that sense mm-hm so we seem to be
transitioning in some ways in the right
direction not at all okay I know the
into it for the Instagram thing is not
it's not at all I was discussing this
with a friend yesterday you know the the
proper way to solve a problem or to
actually set an intention or whatever it
is starts with the why than the what
than the how shared economy is solve is
offering a different how for the wrong
way for the wrong what what is the why
than so here's the question why do we
dress white why do we buy clothes
probably shame we say maybe there is a
bit of decency for the human for I don't
have as much of that shame as other
people but there is so so your city is
cold for this time of the year just so
that you know alright
okay warmth warmth was there you know
this is one of them right the the other
is you really want to to you know cover
yourself somehow right oh gosh we will
be comparing size of genitals than oh my
no we don't want to do that and bad
image now the the the question is is
that why you buy clothes you want to buy
a car to move from A to Z right from A
to B is that why you choose a specific
car you want to buy a phone to browse
the Internet and answer calls is that
why you do it now consumption most of
our consumption is ego-driven it's not
need driven at all right we consume not
because we need we consume because we
want to show the others a side of our
self that is true or not now if you fix
the why you wouldn't need a different
half so why would need to be for need
rather than for ego so so what one of
the you know exercises I discuss which
gets a lot of positive feedback in salt
for a pee is an exercise I call undress
so-so understand there is a utility to
ego there is a utility to ego if you
actually I go here is not defined as
arrogance ego is defined as your as an
identity that you assume for yourself
and you want the world to understand as
you write so I am an engineer gives has
a utility when I tell you that you
understand that this book is not gonna
tell you to say all right if I was a
spiritual leader I you would understand
that this might be about the spiritual
practice if I tell you I am an engineer
you understand there are going to be
equations and a little bit of science in
this right or a lot of science in this
so there is a utility to having that
identity there is however ego in it it's
like if I want to convince you that I am
an engineer and that engineers are
better than others and there are rrragh
then I'm now trying to fulfill that
endless attempt that started when I was
6 or actually I was 3 when I started to
jump up and down and say mommy look at
me I'm doing this right I'm now telling
mommy and everyone else hey look at me
I'm great I'm amazing like why why do we
try to prove that much now what if you
fix in a wireframe yeah yeah if you fix
the why you suddenly own your ego but
your ego doesn't own you anymore right
and that is true success is to realize
that ego is a total illusion
and that it will never actually be
satisfied and that it will constantly be
a moving target and that you will never
ever feel you know settled and peaceful
as long as you're chasing ego I I work
with and I you know I I teach solve for
happy to billionaires billionaires right
and they're still bragging to each other
it's like when does it stop right so
they you know they go to Vegas and they
spend half a million dollars each
because Jesus dude they just want to
show each other that hey I can lose half
a billion dollars can you write they buy
more and more cars not because they need
them but because they want to say look
at me I bought the expensive one and so
on and so forth
ego is never satisfied as long as you're
following it you're gonna follow it for
the rest of your life now the question
is can you fix the why